WE'RE THE ONLY SHOW WHO WILL
EXPOSE THAT AND COVER IT ALL IN
TONIGHT'S BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
THAT'S COMING UP IN A MINUTE.
WE HAVE TO START WITH TONIGHT'S
BREAKING NEWS.
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES ARE
TRYING TO DETERMINE IF F.B.I.
AGENT PETER STRZOK AND HIS
F.B.I. LAWYER GIRLFRIEND LISA
PAGE LITERALLY LEAKED
THAT, IN FACT, THEY HAD ADVANCE
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT A "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" ARTICLE AND IT WAS
ABOUT TO BE PUBLISHED.
NOW TAKE A LOOK AT THIS TEXT
EXCHANGE BETWEEN PAGE AND
STRZOK THAT WAS OBTAINED BY THE
HILL.
PAGE TELLS STRZOK ARTICLE IS
OUT BUT HIDDEN BEHIND PAY WALL
SO CAN'T READ IT.
STRZOK RESPONDS "WALL STREET
JOURNAL"?
BOY, THAT WAS FAST.
SHOULD I FIND IT AND TELL THE
TEAM?
THERE ARE ALSO OTHER TEXT
MESSAGES ABOUT THE MEDIA LIKE
THIS ONE.
STRZOK SAYING YEP, THE WHOLE
PAGE REPLACE MAKES ME FEEL WAY
LESS BAD THROWING HIM UNDER THE
BUS TO THE FORTHCOMING CF
ARTICLE.
ACCORDING AHILL, THEY'RE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHO STRZOK AND
PAGE WERE TRYING TO THROW UNDER
THE BUS.
PAGE SAYS WE HAVE A LIST OF
KIDS WITH THEIR PARENTS' NAMES.
HOW MANY OF THIS REPORTER FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" COULD BE
THERE IN D.C.
THE HILL IS REPORTING STRZOK
INFORMATION ABOUT A "NEW YORK
TIMES" REPORTER THAT THEY WERE
REFERENCING IN THAT TEXT.
WHY WOULD THEY BE LOOKING INTO
A "NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTER?
PAGE THEN WRITES FOUND WHAT I
STRZOK SAYS HE IS TOTALLY
SHLUBBY AND TAKE HORRIBLE SHOTS
AT THE "NEW YORK POST."
CHRIS WALLACE AND MEGYN KELLY,
MOCKING THE TRUMP HOTEL IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. AND SAY THEY
HOPE IT FAILS HORRIBLY.
THEY WOULD NEVER STAY THERE.
BECAUSE OF THE EXISTENCE OF
VARIOUS NEXT MESSAGES THAT
REFERENCE THE NEWS MEDIA
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS ARE
LOOKING INTO IMPROPER LEAKING
TO THE PRESS ABOUT THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
HOW ELSE WOULD YOU INTERPRET
THOSE WORDS?
THEY'LL BE HERE WITH ALL THE
DETAILS COMING UP.
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA, LIBERALS
IN HOLLYWOOD ARE ABSOLUTELY
GIDDY TONIGHT OVER WHAT?
OPRAH WINFREY'S SPEECH AT THE
GOLDEN GLOBES WHICH I WOULD SAY
WAS VERY GOOD.
MANY ARE SAYING AND SHE SOUNDED
PRESIDENTIAL.
IT WAS A CAMPAIGN-STYLE
DELIVERY.
ACCORDING TO NEW REPORTING
OPRAH IS NOW CONSIDERING
RUNNING IN 2020.
HERE IS THE PART OF WHAT OPRAH
SAID AT THE GOLDEN GLOBES.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WANT ALL THE GIRLS
WATCHING HERE NOW TO KNOW THAT
A NEW DAY IS ON THE HORIZON!
>> Sean: TO THE MEDIA, THE LEFT
IN THIS COUNTRY OPRAH IS THEIR
CHOSEN ONE, THE NEW MESSIAH
THEY'LL WORSHIP AND FOLLOW LIKE
THE SHEEP THEY ARE.
HERE IS WHY.
THE MEDIA AND THE LEFT IN THIS
COUNTRY, WELL, THEY NOW SEEM TO
THINK OPRAH IS THE ONE PERSON
THAT CAN HELP THEM FULFILL
THEIR ULTIMATE GOAL.
TO DESTROY DONALD TRUMP AND
DEFEAT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
OVER OPRAH'S SPEECH.
DOES IT REMIND YOU OF THE SAME
PEOPLE THAT NEVER VETTED OBAMA
IN 2007 AND 2008?
SHE IS A VERY LIKABLE PERSON ON
TV AND INSPIRING LIFE STORY.
WATCH THIS.
>> SHE IS KNOWN AS THE QUEEN OF
TALK AND LAST NIGHT THE WORLD
WAS LISTENING.
THE ALL-STAR CROWD CAPTIVATED
BY HER MESSAGE OF FEMALE
EMPOWERMENT, A SPEECH SO
INSPIRING MANY NOW CALLING FOR
HER TO ADD ANOTHER TITLE IN
FRONT OF HER NAME.
PRESIDENT.
>> OPRAH DEFINING THE NIGHT.
BRINGING THE AUDIENCE TO ITS
FEET.
SETTING A NEW TONE FOR
HOLLYWOOD AND MEN AND WOMEN
AROUND THE GLOBE.
>> AFTER THAT SPEECH, SHE HAD
QUITE A FEW PEOPLE IN THAT ROOM
SAYING THEY SURE DID LIKE THE
SOUND OF PRESIDENT WINFREY.
>> IF SHE WERE TO GET IN THE
NEXT DAY SHE WOULD LEAD THE
FIGHT FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION.
>> I WAS BACK IN THE ONE-ON-ONE
ROOMS WHILE THE SPEECH WAS
GOING ON.
EVERYONE WAS MESMERIZED.
>> THAT SPEECH WAS NOT ONLY
EMPOWERING AND INSPIRATIONAL
BUT ECHOED HILLARY CLINTON'S
CONCESSION SPEECH.
DESPERATELY NEEDED THERAPY FOR
ANYBODY WATCHING.
>> SHE GAVE A SPEECH THAT GAVE
PEOPLE HOPE AND REMINDED PEOPLE
WHAT IS SO GREAT ABOUT THIS
STILL HAVE SO MUCH TO BE
HOPEFUL FOR.
>> Sean: THAT DOESN'T SHOW
THEIR BIAS?
IT DOES.
NBC TWEETED AN ENDORSEMENT FOR
FUTURE PRESIDENT.
NBC GOT CALLED OUT FOR BIAS
THEY DELETED THE TWEET AND
TRIED TO SHIFT BLAME TO SOMEONE
ELSE BY PUTTING OUT A STATEMENT
SAYING YESTERDAY A TWEET ABOUT
THE GOLDEN GLOBES AND OPRAH
WINFREY WAS SENT BY A THIRD
PARTY, NOT THEM.
BROADCAST.
IT IS A REFERENCE TO A JOKE
MADE DURING THE MONOLOGUE AND
NOT MEANT TO BE A POLITICAL
STATEMENT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE MSNBC SO.
THE OPERATIVE ARM AND EXTENSION
OF THE PRESS OFFICE.
OF COURSE, OF THE ANTI-TRUMP
MEDIA.
THEY'VE SINCE REMOVED THE TWEET.
REALLY?
A THIRD PARTY AGENCY?
ARE THEY TRYING TO GET SOME
POOR KID FIRED OVER THIS?
NBC GOT CAUGHT RED-HANDED AND
TRYING TO SPIN IT AND HOPE THAT
WE'LL ALL GO AWAY.
LET'S BE HONEST HERE.
WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT NBC
THEY AREN'T FOOLING ANYONE
ABOUT WHERE THEIR POLITICS AND
POLITICAL ALLEGIANCES LIE.
LOOK AT CONSPIRACY THEORY
24/7MSNBC.
HATE TRUMP, THAT'S OUR
PROGRAMMING FOR TODAY.
NBC DESPISE, LOATH, HATE THE
PRESIDENT AND IT'S NOT A SECRET.
SO LET'S ALL STOP PRETENDING
BECAUSE THE GAME IS OVER.
BY THE WAY, NBC WASN'T THE ONLY
DESTROY TRUMP OUTLET TO HEAP
OPRAH?
USA TODAY.
OPRAH 2020, WINFREY'S GOLDEN
DEADLINE OPRAH KICKS OFF 2020.
WHITE HOUSE BID AND OTHER
SURPRISING MOMENTS FROM THE
GOLDEN GLOBE AWARDS.
THE GUARDIAN, COULD OPRAH
WINFREY RUN FOR PRESIDENT AND
WIN?
AND THEN THERE IS HOLLYWOOD.
WERE ALL SHOWN OFF THEIR NEW
FOUND POLITICAL AFFECTION FOR
OPRAH.
THIS IS THEIR NEW SAVIOR.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE IS A MOVEMENT AFOOT
BACK HERE OPRAH 2020.
>> I'M NOT KIDDING.
I AM ALL ABOUT OPRAH 2020.
>> HONESTLY?
PRESIDENT WINFREY IS JUST -- IT
SOUNDS GOOD.
IT ROLLS OFF THE TONGUE.
>> IT COMES OUT --
>> THE IMMEDIATE REACTION
ONLINE?
>> PLEASE RUN.
>> I HOPE SHE RUNS FOR
PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: DID ANY SAY A NICE
WORD ABOUT TRUMP?
THE ECONOMY DOING BETTER IN
EIGHT YEARS.
WHERE DOES OPRAH STAND ON THE
ISSUES?
SHE LAUNCHED A ROCKET TONIGHT.
INTENTION OF DECLARING.
NOW SHE DOESN'T HAVE A CHOICE.
POOR OPRAH, YOUR LIFE IS NOW
COMMITTED.
OTHERS LIKE OBAMA'S FORMER
AS ANY PUBLIC FIGURE DAY.
SHE DOESN'T SPEAK TO CELEBRITY
AMERICA, SHE SPEAKS TO AMERICA.
DON'T UNDERESTIMATE HERE.
CNN POLITICAL ANALYST TWEETED
THIS.
IF OPRAH RAN FOR PRESIDENT IN
2020 SHE IS EVERY PERSON, SHE
HAS BEEN POOR, NOW RICH.
ALSO A SELF-MADE BILLIONAIRE
AND A GRASP OF THE ISSUES AS WE
USED TO COVER LOCAL POLITICS.
CAN ARTICULATE ANY ISSUE AND
MASSIVE APPEAL BEYOND RACE AND
GENDER.
I KNOW YOU PEOPLE IN HOLLYWOOD
AND ALL OF YOU IN THE LIBERAL
MEDIA, I KNOW YOU ARE ALL
INTOXICATED AND ADDICTED TO
LITTLE BIT OF PRESSURE ON THE
BRAKES HERE WITH YOUR OPRAH
OBSESSION.
THOUGHT WAS BRILLIANT IN MANY
WAYS.
WHAT SHE DID LAST NIGHT WAS
GREAT.
SHE STOOD UP FOR WOMEN
ESPECIALLY IN HOLLYWOOD.
I SUPPORT THAT AS I THINK
EVERYONE SHOULD AND I THINK
OPRAH HAS A TREMENDOUS CAPACITY
FOR HUMAN EMPATHY.
SHE HAS AN INCREDIBLE, STRONG
PERSONAL STORY.
OVERCOMING SADNESS AND TRAGEDY
IN A HORRIBLE UPBRINGING.
I APPLAUD HER FOR WHAT SHE HAS
DONE IN HER LIFE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT MUCH ABOUT
HER IN TERMS OF RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
SHE SUPPORTED BARACK OBAMA.
BREATH.
CONTROL YOUR GIDDINESS.
I KNOW YOU HATE TRUMP.
LET'S NOT JUMP ON THE OPRAH
2020 TRAIN JUST YET.
THE ECONOMY HAS NEVER BEEN
BETTER IN EIGHT YEARS.
YOU DON'T LIKE THIS PRESIDENT
STANDS UP TO NORTH KOREA AND
IRAN AND HE IS NOT TRYING TO
BRIBE MURDERING DICTATORS.
YOU'LL HAVE TO GET USED TO
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH BECAUSE
IT ACTUALLY WORKS.
BUCKLE UP.
IT WILL BE A ROUGH THREE YEARS
FROM HERE.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH THE
LEFT.
I WILL NEVER UNDERSTAND WHY
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR A MESSIAH,
A SAVIOR.
SOMEBODY THAT WILL COME IN AND
SAVE THE COUNTRY.
THEY DON'T NEED ANOTHER LIBERAL
CHOSEN TO FIX OUR PROBLEMS WITH
MORE GOVERNMENT.
REAGAN ONCE SAID GOVERNMENT IS
NOT THE SOLUTION, IT'S THE
PROBLEM.
WE NEED MORE INDIVIDUAL FREEDOM
IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE NEED MORE LIBERTY IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE DON'T NEED MORE LIBERAL
POLICIES OUT OF WASHINGTON
LOOK AT WHAT THE LIBERAL IDEAS
DID TO THE ECONOMY AND FOREIGN
POLICY IN THE LAST EIGHT YEARS.
CAN YOU EVEN LOOK?
YOU ALL LOVED OBAMA.
HIS TRACK RECORD WAS ATROCIOUS
AND SO TO ALL OF YOU STAR
STRUCK PEOPLE OUT THERE TONIGHT
LOOKING FOR YOUR NEXT CHOSEN
ONE, YOU MAY WANT TO RELAX AND
STOP TRYING TO BUY YOUR TICKET
ON THE OPRAH 2020 TRAIN.
HERE IS THE OTHER POINT TONIGHT.
THE  HYPOCRISY FROM THE LEFT IS
STUNNING.
IT IS VERY PREDICTABLE.
EVERYONE JUST LIKE IN THE
LIBERAL MEDIA EVERYONE TO A
PERSON PRAISING OPRAH AND BY
THE WAY, TO THE DEGREE
HOLLYWOOD FOR THEIR MOVEMENT
ABOUT ME TOO, ETC.
IT'S GREAT WHAT OPRAH DID BY
STANDING UP FOR VICTIMS OF
WE CAN'T FORGET THAT MISCONDUCT
I DON'T TRUST ANYONE THAT THEY
WERE VICTIMS, YOU KNOW,
ACTUALLY BELIEVE ALL THEY ARE
BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
HYPOCRITES ON THIS SPECIFIC
ISSUE.
FOR EXAMPLE, REMEMBER HOW
HOLLYWOOD EMBRACED ROMAN
POLANSKY.
HE WAS ACCUSED OF RAPING A
13-YEAR-OLD GIRL IN 1977.
AT THE TIME HE WAS 43.
EUROPE BEFORE BEING SENTENCED.
IN THE BUSINESS OF DISOWNING
AND RENOUNCING POLANSKY.
THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
HERE IS WHAT IT DID INSTEAD
BACK IN 2003 HE WON AN OSCAR
FOR BEST DIRECTOR AND THE
CELEBRITY-FILLED AUDIENCE
ERUPTED IN APPLAUSE LIKE I
NEVER HEARD BEFORE EVEN THOUGH
HE CAN'T COME BACK TO AMERICA
BECAUSE HE WAS AVOIDING
AUTHORITIES OVERSEAS.
LISTEN TO THE LEVEL OF CHEERING
WHEN HIS NAME IS CALLED OUT BY
HARRISON FORD.
WATCH THIS.
>> ROMAN POLANSKY.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
>> Sean: REALLY?
HOLLYWOOD'S SUPPORT FOR HIM
DIDN'T END IN 2003 WHEN HE GOT
THE OSCAR.
WHEN HE GOT THE OSCAR IN 2009
AFTER HE WAS ARRESTED IN
SWITZERLAND IN CONNECTION TO
THE 1977 CASE THAT HE RAN AWAY
FROM.
PETITION DEMANDING HIS RELEASE.
SO LIKE I SAID, IT'S ALL GREAT.
HOLLYWOOD, PAT YOURSELF ON THE
BACK, 50,000 AWARD CEREMONIES
AYEAR.
I CAN'T STAND IT OR WATCH A
SECOND OF IT BUT IT REALLY TOOK